In our example,
we have a Client and a Server.
The Client wants to access some
protected data on our Server, but
the Server knows Clients
cannot be trusted.
The Server only wants to give
the data to a trustworthy Client.
So our Client sends a request to our
Server along with data to verify
who it is.
In our example, this user data was
accepted as valid by the Server.
Now instead of saving this user data,
the Server instead creates a token.
This token is returned to the Client and
it's up to the Client to store this data
and send it along as required for
any requests to the Server.
The next time our Client makes a request
along a secure route, it does just that.
It sends along the job token.
But our Server knows
not to trust the Client
because Clients cannot be trusted.
So our Server verifies this token
is who it says it's from and
that it hasn't been tampered with.
If everything checks out like it does
in our example, the Server sends back
a response with the requested data and
everybody lives happily ever after.
And that's a brief overview
of how JSON Web Token work.